ils sont les maîtres du monde titrait ce
matin le quotidien l'équipe salon ainsi
le deuxième titre de champion du monde
de handball de l'équipe de france vous
avez été plus de 11 millions a suivi
hier après midi sur france 2 cette
finale époustouflante les heures qui ont
suivi jusqu'à ce matin furent elles
plutôt festive reportage juliet guichon
joseph d'astiquer sylvain aubin avec un
titre de champion du monde on se refuse
rien et on ne refuse rien aux autres
séances photos autographes
les bleus se sont pliés à toutes les
deux mondes tous et daniel costantini en
particulier peuvent avoir le sentiment
du travail bien fait ce dont je suis le
plus fière finalement c'est d'avoir
amené le handball français à un niveau
de compétitivité au plan international
qui était pas évident au départ
moi ce matin les handballeurs français
étaient invités au comité national
olympique pour y parler de leur aventure
l'attendre
la belle aventure oh ça va permettre de
souder un groupe d amis qui vont j'ai
pas vu des moments de jouer sans ce
qu'on fera pas oublier ben tiens à
remercier tout le monde nous en donner
la possibilité de s'éclater comme on l'a
fait après avoir conquis le monde
les bleus sont partis la nuit dernière à
l'assaut de la capitale dans un grand
cabaret parisien
jackson richardson a montré qu'il savait
faire le spectacle autant sur scène que
sur le terrain
quant à daniel costantini
il a réussi son dernier défi gouttes
chapeau à cette équipe qui a réussi à
chaque fois trouvé les ressources faire
le miracle parce qu'il ya eu des
miracles daste compétition des miracles
toujours des miracles
les handballeurs français se sont
imposés en finale face à la grande
équipe de suède avec ce qu'il faut
d'enthousiasmé de suspense les bleus
sont champions du monde champions du
monde
je